starting for James Ennis hits his first
bucket Anna Rockets have their largest
lead james three-pointer counted LeBron
James he's get along to three and it's
in there for LBJ the down by three that
could tie the game with seven his sexy
years LeBron LeBron for the time of the
evening LeBron with the clock winding
down
long three-pointer homely knocks on he
said they develop McGee is really hard
because he knows he can't release too
much on eight so that's a tough James
steps into the straightaway three
there's a rookie James
[Applause]
this year from downtown me just go ahead
and have him dial it up for you
I did the right thing there plays with
his back to the basket bottoms down
a three-point answer Spence Babylon
quick board between the bar yes
that's settled in nicely attack to get
to the freedom
the broad looking for a thrill see now a
double figure scoring
[Applause]
the blonde right back at you
part played by Jimmy Butler pull it out
largest lead of the game
[Music]
gets three more back we could say the
exact same thing keep it a minute take
him away whoops it's a big one
LeBron and the brunch trying to take
them out of it - coos me here come the
Lakers it's three on three left wing
LeBron he's going to try a three from
over there now same result
Dallas man Dallas Maverick bench steps
back drains it and just like that in box
out Ingram hopefully defended by CJ
volleyed outside where LeBron James
takes over his first three of the
evening really nice visit by Ibaka nice
vision could a kid with your guardian
that guy's you can't leave
Lakers enjoy right back James downtown
who's my operating on the perimeter
LeBron G down zero for LBJ well guys got
a look to help somebody help easy
options
James gathers and knocks down the three
well sudden he's got it going it does
not matter way Folsom topping it for the
year NBA all-defensive Alma champion as
well James for three
back up by three at the end of the
defense possession you don't you pay the
price LeBron James knocks it down
James his third three-pointer the Lakers
backed up by to its event but how about
offensively LeBron James Taj Gibson I'll
see you three and I'll raise you three
should be feeling good about themselves
make your seven to 14 from the field
that's a deep three but we are talking
about LeBron James
[Applause]
lebron james quiets the crowd for a
second
he looks down at got balls random
shooting yep he's got 20 and into the
lead a little bit there was a nine-point
advantage now 9 5
LeBron wise fire and score nothing but
net LeBron James no standards the Mamba
come from fed up I suspect what they're
calling them here is LeBron that's the
king nail it up through 24 years old
third year played all 82 games laughs
you're gonna start all 82 3-pointer
lebra eyes that can create offense on an
extremely high level in their backcourt
of McCullum Camila's James answers with
a three
LeBron James
seven points five rebounds four assists
and in his second three-pointer and in
double figures now with ten Lillard
misses the three about a 7 second
difference between the clocks James
pulls up for a deep
[Applause]
as a flat-out foil this is just smart
two-for-one situation got it going steps
in rhythm and again you mean oh that's
good defense against the great ones you
got to give up something and LeBron
celebrated James another phrase we'll
return to Toronto Michelle Beadle Jalen
Rose Chauncey Billups and Paul Pierce
will company Airways and Chandler's back
on the floor after getting hurt at the
end of the first half he had a huge back
tap in their game last week to beat
Minnesota matched up against the great
Allen Iverson
and when he hit shots like these you
just look over at the coaches there's
nothing you can do because he can get to
the paint anytime he wants
Ron James fires for three
James has been shooting the three-ball
well
blocking foul ball before the basket and
timeout on the court with the limo's 260
of the second quarter here's LeBron
stepping back firing for three his
second three of the game
[Applause]
for three
that's his third three of the game
Winslow working defensively against Jim
shut that three from the inch just
inside the hash mark and buries it no
question he will improve the fortunes of
the heat he's their best option to start
at the four and it's gonna sore subject
for the heat recently the brown James
him five of six from the floor shot
you'll want which is a step-back three
with a hand and a chip there a couple of
years ago here's LeBron against James
Johnson he'll fire up the three Imperial
LeBron James fire here on the first
quickly with this faster paced style of
play more possession you need a little
luck but he has created his own look
taking incredible care of his body
careful what he eats since James left
the heat in the summer 2014 the team he
plays for has not won in this building
that may come to close tonight it's time
in their last 11 games and they will
fall for the fourth straight time at
home LeBron just shot a three giving him
51 points why early and often finishes
with 51 6 of 8 from downtown 19 of 30
150
[Music]